chefs d'état sont donc à berlin pour
tenter de résoudre le conflit libyen
exactement et le but l'objectif
principal de cette conférence et bien et
de consolider cette rave et surtout
d'empêcher toute ingérence étrangère
cette conférence intervient dans un
climat assez tendu entre les deux hommes
forts de la libye faïza sage chef du
gouvernement de tripoli et le maréchal
khalifa haftar plusieurs pays sont
invités à cette conférence car ils sont
impliqués de près ou de loin dans ce
processus de paix vous l'avez dit il ya
la russie la france la turquie
l'allemagne l'italie l'algérie également
et d'autres pays à présent il ya un
grand absent qui a été remarqué la
tunisie qui est pourtant un des pays les
plus impactés par cette crise libyenne
mecha fla l'ambassadeur de tunisie en
allemagne a déclaré qu'il était
extrêmement surpris de cette décision
en tout cas à vers 13 heures vers 14h
pardon les dirigeants vont se retrouver
ici pour faire cette fameuse photo a4
emmanuel macron est déjà arrivé à cette
conférence vladimir poutine et recep
tayyib erdogan sont arrivés aux
alentours de midi alors tous les
dirigeants je voulais dire on se
retrouver ici pour discuter et trouver
des accords sergueï lavrov de son côté a
révélé il ya quelques jours que
plusieurs accords étaient déjà prêts
écoutez le les textes provisoire
à mon avis on sont bien prêts sont était
pratiquement validé par toutes les
parties
ces textes correspondent aux décisions
du conseil de sécurité sur le règlement
les biens ces documents ne contiennent
pas de clause qui serait contraire aux
décisions de l'as du conseil de sécurité
on attend évidemment la position de la
turquie qui soutient militairement
faïza salage merdoie lui vaut sa firme
et s'implanter en tuant libye pardon
puisque c'est le pays africains qui
possède les plus grandes réserves de
pétrole
merci mon hamoud alors en direct de
berlin en allemagne